salut à tous ce nouvel épisode
d'envergure et on va s'intéresser ce
soir non juste le soir donc je dis ce
soir vous l'écoutez quand vous voulez à
un gros gabarit 1 comme comme la semaine
dernière déjà on a décidé de débuter nos
scouting report cette annnée par part de
la taille par du poids par des gros
babar comme dirait nico qui est la salle
unique au salut tout le monde
qui sera là évidemment pour nous faire
découvrir khalifa diop puisque c'est de
lui qu'il s'agit le sénégalais qui joue
à gran canaria en compagnie de alan de
manu et de pierre salut les gars je
précise vous allez prendre l'habitude
comme à chaque podcast en tout cas le
plus souvent possible
le spécialiste de la zone de notre data
team est présent et donc cette fois
c'est pierre pierre b précise puisque on
a deux pierres qui s'occupe de tout ce
qui est en fait europe prospère
internationaux même ceux qui jouent en
australie fin beaucoup de travail pour
toi on va y aller donc c'est khalifa
diop de m onze de 23 d'envergure ça
prend de la place donc comme va
[Musique]
alors on commence par la présentation et
là je me tourne vers nico qui a
forcément mais des petites notes de son
petit cahier oui forcément une
présentation concise pour qu'on voit à
peu près de qui on parle on rentrera
dans les détails c'est à dire son
parcours vraiment les détails de son jeu
un peu plus tard mais vraiment là
quel joueur à ton en face de nous alors
quand on a khalifa dior en face de nos
déjà on est on est un peu mal barré dans
le sens où on ne voit pas l'horizon
voilà deux mètres 11 tu l'as dit de
mettre 23 d'envergure tu l'as dit aussi
c'est une sorte de troncs d'arbres
mobile comme j'aime j'aime l'appeler un
pivot sénégalais qui est arrivé en
espagne sans savoir sans avoir jamais
joué au basket en club et qui ont peu
d'écrire comme un pivot défensif avant
tout le contre le rebond s'est et sa
zone de de savoir-faire en jaune c'était
un point de fixation en attaque
une tour de contrôle en défense pour
l'instant si les adultes c'est un poseur
d'écran et un preneur de rebond voilà
pour la présentation ultra rapide
ok c'est parfait on a compris à peu près
quels sont ses points forts on rentrera
dans les détails après on va donc il
joua à gran canaria et on en parle aussi
puisqu'il sort de du championnat
d'afrique u 18 que vous avez regardé et
donc il ya deux rôles différents on va
commencer en club et en sélection
on va commencer par le club avec toi
pierre à gran canaria
quel temps de jeu et quel genre de
collectif quel genre d'équipé grande
canaria pour ceux qui connaissent pas le
championnat espagnol
wave alors c'est une équipe qui a
l'habitude d'avoir des des joueurs
africains dans ses rangs s'est située
dans les îles au large du sénégal ou
qu'ils ont l'habitude d'avoir des des
joueurs deux régions du parti du mans
ils ont eu un water tavares avance à dix
ans en 2014 et notre
un polonais il me semble en effet passé
ou parce que j'étais en 2017
donc c'est une équipe qui peut faire
zone tampon on fait rentrer le
l'amateurisme et le servir de tremplin
pour les jeunes prospects repère les
africains donc et il tente du malade a
débarqué en déça où ils ont eu sept
matches
par contre mis fin à une campagne
européenne qui est assez bonne parce
qu'ils sont premiers de leur groupe
notamment ils ont le cedevita trento et
d'internât faut donc une équipe qui joue
l'europe aussi nico tu voulais peut-être
ajouter quelque chose sur le contexte
club tout à fait en fait khalifa on a la
chance de le voir cette année parce
qu'ils sont complètement bourré sur le
recrutement et qui n'ont pas de vrai
pivot khalifa le seul vrai préfecture
ouais ok quel temps de jeu pierre pour
khalifa diop qu'elle alors ça varie
selon les matches évidemment mais quelle
quel temps de jeu environ du côté de
vannes des îles canaries
là il est en train de prendre pas mal de
pas mal de responsabilités en fait
depuis deux trois matches ils ont il a
eu son son match référence en eurocup
contre le cedevita hall du ghana où il a
joué 21 minutes team et 14 points 6
passes sur sept est fini avec ses 25
dévale ou ses rangs le facteur x du
match avec un poil bissy et sinon ici
autour d'eux ils oscillent entre 5 et 10
minutes en général donc nico autour de
lui à
dans cette équipe si tu disais c'est le
seul pivot on joue plutôt petit du coup
c'est pas forcément une tendance du
championnat espagnol mais c'est vrai
qu'on joue rarement à deux vrais grands
intérieurs
ah oui ça c'est sûr mais je pense que
ils ont voulu prendre costello et
l'autre son nom mais j kylie kylie dzeko
brûler ces cinq là les deux ils ont
voulu répondre en pensant qu'ils
pourraient tenir le choc au poste de
pivot en ac b en eurocup
et puis il y avait ils se sont
rapidement rendus compte qu'il se
faisait défoncé par tout le monde donc
calé face est imposé et tu parles et
andrew albicy vraiment que c'est moi qui
ai pensé très fortement mais andrew est
un des grands facteurs de l'éclosion de
khalifa parce que francophones 1 parce
que andrew hill il aime bien tutoré ce
genre de jeunes ya une vraie relation
entre les deux
et voilà je pense que j'espère qu'on
aura l'occasion d'avoir rendront
d'ailleurs cette année pour absolument
il était déjà venu donc on va espérer
qu'il revienne dans cette équipe on
trouve aussi sean kilpatrick pour ceux
qui se rappellent également des joueurs
référencé au niveau au niveau européen
et puis au niveau prospère on a le jeune
balseros ce qui motive moi qui joue pas
beaucoup
mon gros et on al jean montéro gens les
gens et si je peux compléter on voit
souvent lorsqu'il sort khalifa a discuté
avec andrew sur le banc et on voit
vraiment allé directement le voir ou ou
aller voir les autres les enseignes
l'intérieur ouais ça apporte de l'eau au
moulin de ce que disait nico vraiment
cette relation privilégiée
andrew albicy khalifa diop manu et alan
maintenant comment ça se passe avec
l'équipe du sénégal alors séparé qui
passaient l'équipe u18
on l'avait déjà vu d'ailleurs au 16 12
il ya deux ans champion du monde 19
points au championnat du monde u 19
vas-y alan commence d'abord avec
peut-être ce qu'il ya autour de lui
avant de parler de son rôle parce que
autour de lui c'est pourquoi ça a été
problématique pour lui en fait
en fait c'était un championnat u18 donc
été en egypte où il y avait quatre
équipes vont en avons parlé entre nous
et odeurs dans l'article qui est sortie
si le week-end dernier sur le site c'est
vraiment ce que moi je voulais mettre en
avant dans l'équipe du sénégal c'est que
c'était la meilleure équipe en terme de
prospects dans les prospects ont à
présent on a présenté cette prospects
nico il y en avait quatre qui venait du
sénégal et pourtant c'est pas l'équipe
qui a gagné
en fait c'est ça le problème c'était que
le niveau de ce que les américains
appellent à coarraze plaît donc le
niveau de jeu des extérieurs créateurs
il est tellement cataclysmiques que ça
pouvait pas mettre en avant la qualité
des pros spéciaux et gallic situés plus
vers l'intérieur donc avec khalifa diop
et hiboux badji le genre car ces
personnes qui d'ailleurs a débuté pour
la première fois en ligue et à ses
délires
oui on en met donc en fait mais donc
deux hommes jouaient pas à son poste
pour moi c'est 1,5 et donc y jouer
quatre et il y avait un manque de space
in flagranti et aucun meneur pour le
mettre dans une bonne disposition est
vrai on a vu avec les intérêts les
prospères intérieur comment c'est
essentiel pour eux d'avoir juste un bon
meneur pour les mettre dans des dents
ses bonnes dispositions que c est fou et
jeff carter aux bulls ou à l'envers ce
jackson à memphis ke qu'elle connaît et
diamants là il n'y avait pas de meneur
le porteur de balle c'était pape sow qui
est en réalité comme le disait le
présenter un nigaud dans l'article est
plus un poste 2-3
car pas l'habitude de porter la balle et
qu'ils aient un meilleur dans le jeu au
volet main c'est lui qui vais créer de
la taxe sur demi terrain donc c'était
très très problématique est en fait ce
que je veux dire c'est après je
laisserais manu mais je tire rien du
champion quasiment rien offensivement du
jeu du choc des quatre matches que j'ai
pu voir parce que on verra jamais un
contexte comme ça donc c'était très
frustrant on fait alors justement toi tu
retires pas grand chose mais manu en
regardant les matchs est ce qu'il ya des
quand même peut-être des duels
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'il nous a
montré puisqu'on va commencer à rentrer
dans ses qualités et défauts à khalifa
diouf qu'est ce qu'il nous a montré sur
ce u18 qui peut être qu'il n'a pas
forcément l'occasion de montrer en club
puisque là peut-être moins de touche le
ballon tout simplement comme il ya eu ni
causé un grand canaria c'est un joueur
qui prend qui fait des écrans en fait
surtout ça en attaque et moi sur ce
championnat d'afrique je l'attendais
surtout offensivement ce pouvoir est ce
qu'il pouvait driver le
le cercle avec vraiment de la puissance
de la qualité vraiment est ce que c'est
une vraie arme offensive dans son jeu à
terme et notamment aussi s'il pouvait je
foutais un peu plus de loin enfin mi
distance et du coup sa gelée au final
comme alan ça se rejoint c'est que il a
il a vraiment en fait eu le même rôle
que la grande canarie et il a beaucoup
fait de d'écran il n'a pas eu forcément
beaucoup la balle en main comme il vous
badji d'ailleurs cas pas fait grand
grand chose et au final je suis assez
déçu de ce point là parce qu'on n'a pas
vu ce qui s'est fait en fait si donc
c'est assez assez étonnant mais il a tu
as quand même posté des petites vidéos
de ce qu'il a pu montrer quand même le
raconte nous un peu donc ça c'est sûr
temps twitter et pour l'arctique dont
parlait alan un article sur envergure
point c'est au notre site pour ceux qui
ne connaîtraient pas et je finis en
disant que le scouting report
écrit par nico est sûre envergure penser
au 6 août à pékin sa job dans la barre
de recherche vas-y manu sur ce que
montre les vidéos que la montée sur sur
khalifa bin sûr le sur le championnat
d'afrique de l'est surtout montré sûr du
tout justement si il a un peu raté il a
pas encore je trouve la puissance et la
gestuelle pour pour s'éloigner vraiment
au delà de 5,6 m mais il l'a montré
qu'ils pouvaient le faire
c'est pas encore ça mais il a montré
qu'ils pouvaient le faire donc ça je
trouve que c'est quand même assez
intéressant et j'imagine que qu'il le
travail avec gran canaria qu'il
continuera le travail et parce que c'est
un aujourd'hui dans le basket ça va être
il va obliger de devoir s'éloigner du du
circuit va pas pouvoir rester devant
dans la peinture à 2 cm du panier c'est
pas possible
rien que pour lui il va falloir qu'ils
pour augmenter son soap en 30 son
potentiel essayer c'est obligatoire donc
là tu c'était vraiment intéressant de
voir qu'il pouvait le faire mais après
il n'y a pas eu assez de
deux tentatives selon moi par exemple
atteint le volume est pas forcément
représentatif de 803 points tentés à
presser le pas c'est pas forcément son
jeu c'est pas forcément ce qu'il voulait
faire
mais ça ça prouve quand même qu'il n'a
pas forcément là la confiance dans son
jeu et ça c'est un peu un peu refusé dé
tir ouverte qui puisque 81 8 parce que
t'as que 8 tirs ouverts a aussi oui non
non il en progrès mais c'est vraiment
des fois il gardait la balle et y
revenez sur son honneur ou quoi ne sais
pas je ne sais pas si c'est de la
confiance je sais pas je sais pas trop
d'où ça vient mais j'ai trouvé ça un peu
dommage parce qu'il l'a il la montre qui
pouvait le faire donc c'est là dessus
c'est ça va être intéressant de voir le
futur comment il va il va améliorer ça
il en a mis combien sur 8 2 2 bon 8
c'est mieux que zéro et c'est moins bien
que 18
je suis là pour enfoncer les portes
ouvertes nico tu voulais dire un mot sur
le tube 18 justement je trouve et alan
du rebond après c'est étonnant ça tient
manuela à un peu dit ce que je voulais
dire c'est qu'il va parler d'eux tu
tiens à trois points parce que justement
pour moi la seule chose que je retiens
de l'offre 18 par rapport à khalifa
c'est que ok il a pris que 8 hier un
cinq matches il y en avait pris quatre
en sept matchs pendant le fiba world u17
donc il a doublé sur le match il a
doublé et surtout par rapport à un
commentaire à son point de départ
c'est à dire je suis à trois points je
regarde même pas le cercle tu as trois
points je cherche à qui je peux faire la
passe maintenant
il l'a même s'il n'est pas c'est clair
que les palettes d'appel touche il n'y a
pas la rotation mais il travaille
beaucoup sur le tir à 3 points donc
je pense que et des onguents quand on
voit pas les projections moi je pense
qu'il va pouvoir être un un shooter
descend jamais au straits five mais un
shooter décentrement très bien badge à
la mécanique moi je trouve la mécanique
est plutôt intéressante aux
lancers-francs déjà le lait le
pourcentage est horrible mais je trouve
que la mécanique et bien nous blesse un
point de départ et ce qui est bien dans
la mécanique
si on peut préciser ben je trouve que
c'est vraiment droit il a vraiment le
lelangue le droit au niveau du poignet
et c'est vraiment intéressant ne s'est
pas cassé comme l'extrême lonzo bolton
là c'est vraiment droit accès il ya pas
de y'a pas de fioritures dans son geste
en fait d'ailleurs la photo qui assure
notre site elle montre assez bien
l'alignement poignet coude genou enfin
on voit que le haut du corps mais on
voit que c'est bien alignées en revanche
la main gauche un peu au dessus du
ballon j'ai l'impression par rapport à
un shoot académique après comme disait
romain si ça rentre ça rentre au niveau
physique puisque on nous a présenté une
espèce de ta dit quoi un tronc d'arbre
qui bouge nico c'est ton expression
pierre qu'est ce que tu peux nous dire
d'autre à propos de ces autres attributs
physiques et ce qu'il est fort et ce
qu'il a de la force parce qu'on peut
être musclé pas forcément fort comment
ils se déplacent vers l'avant vers
l'arrière comment ils se déplacent sur
les côtés ça c'est je pense que c'est
déjà sa qualité principale ça va être sa
force il n'a pas l'air d'être il a que
18 ans faut le rappeler il a pas l'air
d'être un enfant milieu des adultes il a
l'air d'être à sa place même si c'est
pas le plus fort mais il peut finir il
peut absorber le contact déjà sur le
banc match qui fait contre le cedevita
on voit plusieurs fois des des joueurs
adverses jeté sur lui il arrive à finir
j'ai vu des d un match lui
l'année dernière dans la les playoffs de
la catégorie junior en espagne où il
arrivait aussi à figaro contacter mme
koch
c'est pas mal après il a des range très
haute et un peu de mal à switcher sur
les sur les sur les meneurs il arriva à
friser les pick and roll mais je trouve
qu'il est lisse et souvent prendre de
vitesse on peut le voir contre nanterre
quand connaissent et des formes series à
la corde signé il se passer directement
à aimer un coup de hanche ou un coup de
bras il fait tomber la faute ok donc un
petit manque de mobilité nico est ce que
c'est un manque d'expérience de
placement vraiment effectivement eu un
truc structurels chez lui là on parle
d'un gamin de 2002 face à sézanne hier
mais bien sûr c'est pour ce que je te
demande
et ouais parce que dans pour un poste 5
sa mobilité elle est vraiment bonne les
si on regarde sur sur les matchs de da
cb sur le même eurocup sur certains
matches c'est pas s'est pas baladé
maillot mais c'est un gars qui avec qui
est capable de tenir le premier
dirigeable jusqu'à ce que son joueur
puisse revenir et repartir lui voit sur
ce qu'ils vendent au dribble il est
capable d'accompagner après pire a dit
un truc super important il a parlé de
faute
aujourd'hui défensivement avec le corps
qu'il a il y va alors qu'ils propre
équilibre entre son enthousiasme et
défendre et c'est pas encore ça
par contre pour te parler un peu de
fierté après je te laisse parler manu
faut savoir que c'est un gars dont les
coéquipiers se plaignent fréquemment ils
vont voir le coin de chanteuse en faut
dire à qui avait fait qu'il arrête parce
que quand il pose un écran il fait pas
semblant très bien on ça c'est
intéressant
manu vas-y tu vas là quelque chose eh
bien c'était pour revenir sur les fautes
dont parlait nikos et en plus c'est
souvent des fautes bêtes des fois c'est
vraiment des choses quand il va
apprendre
il les fera beaucoup beaucoup moins on
est par contre je reviens un peu sur ce
qu'a dit pierre franchement moi je
trouve c'est pareil au niveau 2 du
switch en défense il est quand même
vraiment capable de tenir la dragée
haute à certains mineurs c'est la
deuxième vidéo que j'ai et que j'ai fait
vous pouvez aller voir ou franchement il
tient vraiment le la corde
franchement je trouve ça assez
intéressant quand même deux vivent pas
ce qu'il va encore progresser une comme
nicolas lilas il l'a pas il joue pas au
basket depuis depuis dix ans donc ça et
c'est un grang sa progression havas air
dans cinq dans cinq ans là on va voir
vraiment le joueur qu'on a quasiment
fini
c'est là qu'on pourra vraiment juger du
du du joueur et il faut essayer de du
coup de projeter à une cession qui peut
qui peut être dans cinq ans à la no
comment tu juges sont justement ces
défenses sur sur écran nico avait l'air
de dire sur un dribble ça va peut-être
que sur le changement de direction ou
sur deux trois dribbles ça va pas en
tout cas on n'est pas sûr du il peut
sortir il pas switcher complètement
comment tu juges c'est sa protection de
cercle dans l'ensemble franchement
j'aime bien je sais positif mois sur
après le après avoir vu parce qu'en fait
il était le deuxième protecteur de
cercle sénégal il faisait beaucoup de de
woodside en fait pendant le l'afro et 18
passes qui ont été badgées la tour de
contrôle en fait du du sénégal donc
ensuite j'ai été voir il est il a
rejoint en eurocoupe la semaine passée à
pesaro où il est sorti du banc alors que
ce qui est intéressant ici aussi c'est
qu'il est titulaire en eurocoupe ans il
commence les matches donc
c'est aussi une ceni jean montéro et
joue même pas en europe
donc à mon grand désespoir mais il joue
pas et en fait non je moi défensivement
je le trouve super intéressant et c'est
si les prix au premier tour de la draft
là cette année ou l'année prochaine ça
sera avant tout pour son profil défensif
son profil de pivot protecteur de cercle
dissuasif qui a une mobilité franchement
bonne pour son pour son poids pour son
son physique
alors oui switcher de 1,5 compliquée
mais qui switch de 1,5 vrai réellement
une biais des l'élite de l'élite des
athlètes et des des pivots donc non
franchement moi je suis je trouve bon la
protection de serre bon la dissuasion we
thought encore un peu sur les feintes
ses défauts de bêtes comme l'a dit manu
mais tous les pivots de 18 ans font ces
fautes là c'est très très rare de voir
un piot 18 ans très bon lecture sur
feinte et les proches du poignet moi je
trouve je suis vraiment positif sûr sûr
sûr ça et offensivement parce que j'aime
bien c'est est ce que je trouve son côté
c'est son jeu de passe je le trouve
intéressant à la passe merci bravo tu
vous êtes par les avants et anglais ou
faire un câlin d'une autre bouche tu pas
fou non je viens ici je vais voter sur
mon carnet moi aussi je le notais voilà
pierre je voulais donner la parole là
dessus peut-être sur le jeu de passes et
sur le jeu offensif qu'est ce que tu as
vu d'autres tu parlais de petites
finitions main gauche je parlais de de
quelques absorption de contact qui était
intéressante qu est ce que tu peux nous
dire d'autre part nous peut-être de sa
pose d'écrans
on en a touché un mot assez rapide mais
finalement est ce qu'ils les pauses dans
le beau temps dans le bon timing en août
ça c'est quelque chose de primordial
pour l'écran alors par rapport à ce qui
a été dit avant moi je sais pas je l' ai
vu un peu sur des écrans qui sont posées
ou n'arrivent pas vraiment cadres et les
appuis du du piquet et ça fait que
souvent c'est des écrans qui vont
retarder un petit peu le défenseur
adverse parce que c'est une bûche comme
fenêtre unique aux seniors on peut
mettre du temps à le contourner
mais il va pas vraiment ils vont ils
vont pas lui rentré dans le temps si
j'ai le temps qu'il a encore un peu soft
sur les sur les écrans ou kill ten qui
met de l'impact mais qu'il est les
parents très bien mais c'est intéressant
un manu sûr toujours sur le côté
offensif par alan a touché un mot du jeu
de passe qu'est ce que tu peux te dire
d'autre là dessus c'est que qu'est ce
que vous appelez un bon sens de la passe
pas ce que ça veut dire quoi c'est à
dire des passes depuis le poste à venir
dépassent en short roll ce qu'il a les
deux et ce qui passe dès demain soyons
précis n'ont ils pas ce dès demain oui
comme tout le monde mais ils peuvent y
en a une main dès demain j'ai vu des
pulls et les équipes en tête mais je les
ai vu faire des petites passes à une
main aussi c'est je te trouvais
intéressant dans le fait qu'ils diraient
ils à la tête haute et y va il va pas au
couteau arrêté son dribble il va arriver
c'est de trouver la bonne personne
trouve ça super intéressant après c'est
pas un passeur naissance à 100 il ne
sera jamais mai mais un peu à l'image
d'un homme à ivan et vas y vas trouver
la petite pas ce qui va décaler le
l'attaqué et qui va être plus la bonne
passe pour pour le panier bonjour je
trouve ça vraiment vraiment intéressant
c'est peu et c'est une âme qui vive si
je pense va il doit surtout il doit il
doit continuer à la halle atral à
travailler à un maximum parce que ce
serait encore venu une arme en plus dans
son jeu nico
est-ce que tu avais quelque chose à
ajouter sur le jeu offensif
ou est ce qu'on passe ça n'a pas
énormément parler de la défense non
porteurs comme alan en a parlé
rapidement quand même le point de vente
enfin l'argument de vente pardon du
pivot nba moderne
sur ce on se sent jeu offensif il ya
deux choses on n'a pas parlé c'est qu'on
n'a pas le tir à trois points mais le
tir à mi distance il est de plus en plus
à l'aise sur du catch and shoot
donc ça peut être intéressant qu'il est
capable quand il joue dos au panier il a
montré chez les jeunes pas encore chez
les grands de se retourner sur ses deux
épaules et donc de finir avec des hooks
main gauche main droite ça il a après le
haendel est catastrophique en même temps
c'est un pivot mais bon il ya eu ni
pourra pas on va parler d'eux mêmes
blocages billy tout à l'heure c'est pas
mon cas j'ai dit ça c'est sûr et après
ya un problème dans le catch de ya un
problème de d'attraper donc c'est quoi
il a des gros doigts
il est gros doigts boudinés peut-être
rien un manque de touché en tout cas
et c'est assez fou de voir à quel point
on peut avoir des bonnes mains dans la
finition parfois près du cercle et à
quel point parfois l'impression qu'ils
jouent avec des moufles moi donc ça
c'est un problème sur lequel ils
travaillent quotidiennement à gran
canaria pour pour essayer de l'améliorer
moi ce que j'ai lu en termes de
motricité fine c'est que à partir de 6
ans c'est 90% c'est mort tatata tout
développer ou pas donc du coup ils vont
essayer de travailler sur les 10%
restants pour pour en faire un quelqu'un
capable d'attraper de manière correcte
wells rsa sera jamais ça jamais anthony
davis là dessus ça c'est sûr mais
évidemment qui a dû beaucoup travailler
avant ses 6 ans du coup pierre pour le
rebond a pour parler du rebond est-ce
que du coup il a aussi cessé des doigts
qui glisse sur les rebonds et ce qu'il
utilise bien son potentiel puisque quand
on voit la taille le poids
l'envergure on se dit ça doit être ma
xin a gobé du rebond bas alors là je
veux bien la vie des autres aussi parce
que je les ai vus donc du coup sûr le
match de l'année dernière contre les
jeunes
excellent au box out c'est vraiment
contre les autres très grand vous pouvez
avoir des problèmes quelques ballons qui
glisse mais là en senior en adulte j'ai
l'impression que il souffre un peu de
son de manque d'explosivité
je sais pas ce que les autres en pensent
mais oui il est grand il a des longs
bras mais j'ai l'impression que c'est
pas le plus explosif pour aller chercher
le ballon très haut et il n'a pas l'air
toujours très très impliqués ou pas
toujours à 100% intéressant à l'âne ou
manu sur l'explosivité vers le haut
la vitesse vers le haut en fait ouais
c'est pas c'est pas prêt je sais le
choix a hong kong ou pas c'est pas ce
jour là c'est plus philippe lucet un
tronc en fait comme a dit mais quand tu
es un tronc et que tu lève les bras au
un peu rattrapé les rebonds mois sur le
bal championnat d'afrique u 18 en terme
de groupe i de meneur on n'était pas
servi mais en terme de
pivot est grand il y avait de quoi faire
donc on l'a vu et je les ai vus solide
en fait solide au rebond oui les pas et
qu'il n'a pas une excellente explosivité
verticale et encore c'est encore c'est
assez dur quand même je trouve pas ce
qu'il est non moi j'ai pas de
franchement défensivement c'est un
prospect immérité tarte au premier tour
mais pour leur compte pour la protection
de cercle pour le sens du contre sur
deuxième rideau pour la la capacité
potentielle à switcher après will c'est
pas un athlète explosif plus plus en
termes d'explosivité verticale de jump
et tout ça mais ça reste quand même un
excellent un super athlète pour ces ses
dimensions physiques la tâche par louis
où alex jeu là dessus je trouve que on
peut entre badji est bon ce qui nous
écoutent pour ceux qui écoutent un
podcast pour khalifa diop à mon avis
savent qu'ils équilibrent ou badji donc
beaucoup je fais la comparaison
badji quand on voit ça saute aux yeux
qu'il est athlétique califano
mais c'est pas pour ça qu'il est
pathétique il ya quelques contres il ya
quelques rebonds ou tu vois que la main
elle est en haut du carré blanc et je
pense que c'est un peu comme maledon
eyes à ses terres que le côté athlétique
de eyes sont beaucoup plus odieux que ma
des dons par contre le jour au mali dont
il doit aller choper 1re bourse il a
vraiment envie d'aller choper vous allez
vous rendre compte qu'il est athlétique
est bon et femmes pour moi c'est un peu
la même chose très intéressant la
question qu'on se pose du coup je vais
la poser à manu un mec qui veut jouer
grand en nba aujourd'hui il doit être
capable de donner de l'espace
verticalement à son équipe donc d'aller
attraper des allées ou est-ce qui est ce
qu il sait le faire esquisser ce qui est
vraiment il pèse sur le jeu et sur les
défenses du coup allé à lyon puis les
cas c'est sûr quand il est bien servi et
qu'on le voit surtout parce que c'est
pas le cas tous les meneurs de rendre
canaria je tairai leur nom parce que je
les connais pas mais franck et ferrat et
ouais un petit blanc
mais c'est fin des phases i il fait tout
ce qu'il faut le pic le rôle il est tout
seul il y avait les mains et ne se passe
rien donc c'est assez
mais autrement il peut le faire jusque
là pas une info sur like sur l'écran
total eux rendus sur l'écran je trouve
pas qu'il ait une détente
ouf après je ne sais pas si elle a été
mesurée ou sinico à des inside là dessus
mais mais il fait pas le le gars qui va
qui va bondir au dessus du cercle et
tout dégommer quoi l'amanite je te
laisse la parole sur l'attitude du coup
puisque ça peut être très frustrant de
tout faire correctement et qu'on vous
donne pas le ballon est-ce que qu'est ce
que tu as aimé moins aimé dans son
attitude sur le terrain que ce soit à
gran canaria ou ou lors du championnat
d'afrique
monsieur roy agbank cannage vous trouve
c'est un avis après je ne sais pas ce
qu'en penseront les autres mais je
trouve quand même toujours concentré
dans ce qui faillit moi je n'ai jamais
vu et les mains sur les genoux en train
de en train de souffler et de retourner
en défense en marchant tu vas y tu
confirmes je confirme il ya juste
quelques fois c'est pas le premier
revenir en défense peut-être aussi à
cause de ses mensurations en saut son
gabarit aussi très bien manu vas-y gt gt
coupé mais le nôtre en moi je le trouve
vraiment impliqué dans le jeu que ce
soit en attaque ou en défense elle voilà
le sujet 20 en tout cas si les
différentes rencontres que j'ai vu ça
m'a pas sauté aux yeux nico on va parler
de des informations qu'on peut avoir sur
l'attitude du prospect qui est un
élément évidemment primordial sur ce que
tu as pu comprendre apprendre bons
élèves comme disait ma nuque ou bon
élève et surtout coéquipiers
irréprochable dans le
le groupe de joueurs sénégalais qui
évolue en espagne qui a été formé en
espagne qui est assez nombreux à mars il
a c'est le boss c'est le mec que tout le
monde craint tout on respecte khalifa
c'est le grand frère khalifa c'est celui
qui va taper les textos en espagnol pour
les sénégalais qui n'ont pas encore
comment dire qu'ils n'ont pas encore
pris langue vivante 1 espagnole quoi
c'est c'est le lien entre ceux qui
viennent du sénégal ou d'afrique en
général avec un dirigeant avec les
coachs c'est quelqu'un de très calme et
en fait quand je faisais la comparaison
ait mal et donc par rapport à ça au côté
athlétique badji diop il ya un truc
aussi c'est que quelle faille quelqu'un
de très introverti badji extraverti et
badji tu le vois ça explose son côté
athlétique et khalifa il va le faire
uniquement quand il en a besoin je pense
que pareil dans la danse dans la dans le
caractère je pense qu'il ya un truc qui
doit qui doit tu dois être liés il
arrive en espagne quand en u16
donc il y en a il avait 14 ans il finit
la saison avec 19 rebonds de moyenne et
le petit club de terral phase qui à côté
d'alicante et a été en finale
donc ils ont ils ont ils ont sorti les
gros et ils ont ils sont allés en finale
du championnat national a eu 16 refusé
par barcelone signé par gran canaria
mais en fait à l'époque là on le voit il
est affûté de dengue est en fait c'était
un petit gros quand il signe à gran
canaria
c'était un petit gros chi x et les
meilleurs à les anciens petits gros
c'est ça c'est ça et donc du coup ils
ont vachement hésité parce qu'ils
pouvaient pas faire des gros efforts ils
étaient très lents pour prendre des
décisions mais en fait le gros truc qui
moi me fait penser à vincent poirier par
rapport à khalifa diop c'est que les
deux sont arrivés tard mais les deux
sont des éponges
les deux sont irréprochables dans
l'attitude et du coup ben
il continue d'apprendre on parlait du
rôle d'andrew le fait qu'il est il est
un endroit le buisson dans son équipe va
tellement lui faire du bien parce qu'en
fait khalifa il a juste besoin qu'on lui
expliquer qu'on lui montre donc andrew
m'expliquer sur les pick and roll ben tu
lui dis mais toi là et puis après tu
couple l'a pas là le pick and roll
d'après il est à l'endroit où tu l'a
demandé et il attrape là et puis du coup
il est content et donc du coup voilà il
ya il y a ce côté là très important je
pense qu'il fallait mettre en avant par
rapport à son background c'est qu' il
n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de drapeau
jaune non il n'ya pas de red flag lui
tous les feux sont au vert quoi donc
c'est aussi ça qui fait je pense que
manu à la bière toi et moi on soit aussi
en plusieurs
on n'est pas en train de dire que c'est
que c'est hakeem olajuwon
pas du tout je pense qu'il est plus
proche de bismack biyombo que hakeem
olajuwon mai mais il a tellement de
trucs pour lui que je pense qu'il y
arrivera les probabilités d'échec en
tout cas sont plus réduites que pour
doter si on peut le formuler comme ça
alan sur la projection on est ce qu'on a
oublié quelque chose de dire quelque
chose sur un rôle potentiel qui pourrait
avoir dans la nba moderne
est-ce que tu as une comparaison en
termes de rôle évidemment et pas en
terme de deux joueurs
je pense que c'est un joueur qui met
franchement bons élèves sur la mécanique
du foot s'est jamais chris thompson non
mais moi c'est compliqué tu me prend au
dépourvu mais je vais je vais je vais me
remettre sur mes deux potes
moi je pense déjà que c'est un genre tu
y seras backup
dans ses premières années et ce qui va
venir si directement quand il va se
faire a draftés ça on ne sait pas
potentiellement mais on n'y a pas
vraiment d'un énorme échantillons il
faut vraiment une équipe pour élire
voilà est-ce que tu entre 7h et tu
fermes une saison complète en liga à cb
je compare pas mais c'est ce que fait
paul marot par exemple installé du côté
du barça mais non pivot backup poseurs
d'écran défenseur qui joue 15 minutes
dans la ligue dans les premières années
et sur qui à qui on va demander de
shooter à trois points je pense je pense
que ça va être nécessaire pour lui je
pense que ce sera nécessaire de bien
shooté aux lancers francs 2 être utile
sur du pick n pop alors et dur du pick
and pop notamment sur short roll c'est
assez compliqué pour le moment comme il
a comme l'a dit nico je crois c'est le
dribble et les dribbles les
problématiques mais c est un pass est un
passeur fonctionnel c1 c'est à dire que
c'est un pass n'est pas en passe mais
qui fait des passes flashy c'est pas un
gars qui fait des différences sur les
passes mais c'est un gars qui ne coupent
pas l'action quand il a la balle en main
et c'est très important tout simplement
appris à faire les bonnes passes comme
danseur nico si c'est une éponge c'est
un peu facile d'atteindre je mettais en
avant l'an passé sur les à coco ses
impasses des passeurs fonctionnel et
c'est hyper-important pas couper
l'action donc s'il fait sa ligne s'il
est bon dans ses pas cela si il mettant
sur pick'n peuple et que pas sur du riz
me renie les il arrive à bien finir et
que défensivement c'est le profil qu'on
a dressé c'est un joueur qui est un qui
peut être un back up on me manu est ce
que tu as quelque chose à ajouter sur la
projection du joueur ou est ce qu on
clôt le chapitre khalifa diop et on
passe à la chronique du nico maintenant
je vais laisser mikko par les grands
seigneurs
allez on rajoutera un jingle au montage
[Musique]
baradar
existe
[Musique]
la tactique c'est laid
c'est rangé en n 6 de bones européen
donc à chaque fois tu va nous présenter
un profil alors avec la projection qu'il
faut mais généralement ça va pas
forcément être des profils top 30 parce
que sinon on leur consacre un peu de
casse en entier donc ça plus est des des
candidats entre le 30 et la 100e place
quoi qui est ton choix pour ce preuve
cette première version stable à j'ai
choisi une option très courtisé au
scrabble puisque c'est énormément de
points mahmoud el hajri donc comme son
nom l indique il est portugais tenant
bien évidemment il est géorgien il est
né à new york mais il a grandi à
tbilissi c'est un poste 4 2 qui est nés
en 97 anecdotes familiales j'adore sa
grand mère a été capitaine de l'équipe
du rss de basket féminin à n'importe qui
s'avoue pays
c'est clair et bien évidemment son idole
c'est et bien j'allais dire oh gaby tu
es sergei bubka
giuly a oui je suis qui je vais donc y
donne la tra pachulia et qui est il un
poste 4
on se dit alors que c'est très bien
c'est un poste 4 qui est tout sauf un
cliché des géorgiens
bon les géorgiens c'est un peu les
nigérians de l'europe là on a un but
mobile en genre nouveau un stretch port
géorgien que d'habitude c'est plutôt des
joueurs qui brasse à l'intérieur qui
font de m kim est dépeint là c'est
plutôt des styles five d'habitude c'est
ça et donc là voilà ses déliés sa cour
bien au niveau athlétique on va dire que
c'est bien pour l'europe c'est un petit
peu en dessous de la moyenne pour pour
le les états unis c'est pas très
puissant très puissant c'est pas un
super screener pour son gabarit
par contre là où il s'éclate basse et
pick and roll alors le plus étonnant
c'est qu'il est je vais dire souvent non
on va dire quatre à cinq fois par match
il est initiateur de pick and roll
il se passe jamais beaucoup de choses
derrière mais c'est il joue comme un
deuxième meneur il veut il veut tout le
temps la balle il veut remonter la balle
il met du rythme après là où son coach
et moi et tous ceux qui le regardent le
préfère c'est quand il pose des écrans
et qui ensuite puis quel camouflet
il peut il peut rouler aussi mais il lui
faut de l'espace
voilà ça c'est le côté offensif au
niveau des dribbles
je pense que c'est le joueur de 2 m 11
si on enlève pour coup c'est pourquoi ce
ski que j'ai vu le plus terrible et de
ma vie il aime beaucoup le spin
pour l'instant il explose un petit peu
au contact des gros donc c'est plutôt à
l'extérieur de la raquette qu'on le voit
briller les basques et vendeurs parce
qu'ils vendent leurs terrains
un shoot si on devait déjà dire sens où
c'est sa taille sa mobilité et son tir
oui que tu savoir de plus cette année
bah tu as dit qu'ils jouent assez town
hall pas ah pardon j'ai pas dit qu'il
était chez les pirates de cette drôle
effectivement un des meilleurs logos de
paysages initié la sem verde absolument
avec art djebar est oui 40 34 % à 3
points en carrière sur ggg au moment où
on enregistre 2 114 tentatives n'ont
cessé assez conséquent pour pouvoir dire
que lucerne pourcentage correct et cette
année il est presque à 5 3 points par
match évidemment il ajouté neuf matches
pour l'instant mais sa 4ème année à
l'université il a il a testé un peu les
eaux pour la draft
il a retiré son nom il prend il espère
être drafté cette année pour l'instant
je n'ai pas vu dans beaucoup de moc
si ce n'est dans aucune
mais il ya quelque chose il ya quelque
chose dans le profil
il va falloir qu'ils bossent beaucoup
sur le jeu posté qui nous propose autre
chose que des passants parce qu'il fait
uniquement ça il travaille jamais pour
lui au poste
défensivement sur les clauses out c'est
un peu catin sur les aides défensives en
général c'est un peu kata parce qu'il
est obnubilé par le ballon lui il est à
0,4 contre par match c'est quand même
parce que pour les interceptions à
l'arrivée un peu plus d'une amende et
main active
il est toujours en train de chercher le
l'interception sur la passe ebook soft
constamment donc ça c'est bien mais par
contre voilà le les clauses out et les
aides défensives c'est il se cherche un
profil rare néanmoins dans plus de 20 %
de passes décisives perd assez peu de
ballons quand même malgré son le fait
qu'ils le demandent beaucoup va sur la
ligne un taux correct si je regarde le
profil statistique et ça correspond à
peu près ce qui se passe en match sur la
ligne des lancers-francs parle
évidemment peut-être rwe va alors
falloir mieux défendre en gros à l'âne
si on devait compléter les produits
propos de nico web puisqu'il peut jouer
je pense que c'est là pour la nba à une
pièce est la question
- pour l'europe chose mais j'adorais de
l'année dernière avec mike powell c'est
le mur genre de l'équipe est franchement
est ce que c'est la tour de contrôle
offensive cette fois-ci par rapport à un
job qui était la tour de contrôle
défensive mais depuis c'est un gaucher
c'est un bon passeur il a un triple
sympa non moi j'aime bien manu est ce
que tu as vu ma me trompe peut très bien
numéro 23 de ses town hall donc présenté
par nico pour cette première chronique
on verra si mam qu'est la juve il y donc
vous pouvez l'appeler mamie on va se
contenter de manu ça nous évite
évidemment de
ap trop de l'être merci messieurs merci
à tous pour tous à nico je t'ai pas
demander est ce que tu avais d'autres
infos sur myspace d'infos sous le
manteau vert oui la première fois que
j'ai vu c'était en 2015 early junior il
était prêté à l'as tu es là tu joues un
roumain un super gars très bosseur n'ont
pas de une famille de sportifs va tout
et tout est stable sur le côté de
comportement et appuyer wagram il ya pas
de pas de yellow flag non plus merci
nico merci à l'âne merci manu et merci
pierre on se retrouve très bientôt pour
un prochain épisode d'envergure d'ici là
vous pouvez aller sur notre site vous
pouvez aller vous abonner sur votre
plateforme d'écouté préféré puisqu'on
est quasiment partout et puis vous
pouvez aller consulter soit nos réseaux
sociaux twitter rien soit instagram bien
puisque nous sommes sur les deux des
nouveaux sports régulièrement des vidéos
les infos sur les os paix ciao à tous et
à bientôt